[Music]
hey if you can't get your coat overlap
servcie too big and come here don't let
that arm take your sweetness you got
that showdown
right don't lose that you don't have the
triangle keep going in your shoulders to
fall out fall out yeah okay so that you
break his posture okay he's not not
stack
okay then get your other hand out of
there
secure your grip in there okay now
finished it dangle is running in saving
the day but you can't open it to get
that no you gotta prioritize the
elements okay if you're in the vertical
you're more prone to stack this so you
might get over here let's go when you
put out
[Music]
get that hand eat but it you're not
going close
[Music]
wait wait
anyway yeah
[Music]
elbow and try to get your trips over
okay even this it's too clean too
reliant even get it this and then you're
gonna move slightly this way you can see
the angle you need to put off that
weight right here on it now you're gonna
know don't open it
start to lift it look over there you go
[Music]
luxury kicks to the face like come on
threatened Zack Zack Zack Zack okay
yeah okay so once what if you get her if
you get her like this right so remember
this movie this movie for them okay then
you so the other one is I'm gonna like
this I can't go like this was gonna
he'll kick me in the face yeah so you
have to be aware of that but you got you
got her here she stack she folded
herself right go ahead and take that
hood this way hey if I try to try to try
to I do jujitsu right okay there's a lot
of muscle oh sweet dude okay take your
mouth your mouth
[Music]
okay you take okay that you wanted yeah
all right so look I'm not I'm not used
in any straight and I try not to give
try not to use all my weight we get it
so tap out wouldn't equate you don't
like this you see how he's not having
out so I don't have all my weight on him
you get it that's how you have to go
smaller people in your training okay so
you see how much you can move is it
what's going to happen right so we're
going right
[Music]
he's needless libera see how I got
around hi
I still have his hip here then I come
out and the general not your question
him
he's got wait a lot earlier there's no
way dump him I'm letting him with
[Music]
you see it is or it's doing all that
bracing right you kind of caution us on
that but just work with it
they get to tap out when you want
[Music]
okay that's not what I'm doing
he goes I'm letting it move good good
look how much lower it gets in the lock
it look come back and walk in with two
feet bridge good there you go good
you're breathing too hard you don't have
it now don't lose what you got
[Music]
good
love it right
[Music]
whoa you see an echidna my waist not
really long you what you are because
you're just I don't know I don't want to
call it wrestling because this is not
even good wrestling you're bad just by
you pushing and pushing okay
try to think of your rolling sessions
it's just micro drilling without clear
[Music]
starting and stopping okay not I'm in a
grappling match okay the point is to
have more dynamic starting positions to
the techniques you're going to use
because you're trying to get a
application Felicity to your faces okay
so I'm gonna talk so you can see that
come closer so here I'm not trying to
get out of side control you get it I'm
not gonna I'm not going to go like this
I'm gonna wait for certain openings to
happen okay and I begin my basics from
there he's gonna do something
[Music]
go ahead you can throw your strikes that
helps me
[Music]
so that's my opening then it would be
like we start again begin it now I just
made the beginning clear
[Music]
okay
- see I'm following ancient rings not
this
okay let's try a lighter gotta get going
have a face if China lost it don't look
at me while you're painting good stock
of the body go back go back
you mind get that leg on your shoulder
put his leg on your shoulder check when
you come up stack him from there Zack go
round the leg yes
drop your head good so what this is
guarding his ribcage you seen hi so
don't throw it there right nothing's
burning his face right
take this hand hold his arm you see that
keep this tight so you can't do anything
with that arm right here boom boom
[Music]
and you do it again no do you understand
me now you let it out okay so the
Charlotte shirt right this is arms here
okay no don't strike here your own arms
in the way of your knee notes right here
he has that hand his hand guard guard
guard
yes here's the free one on this side
here okay are you gonna hit without
opening in there boom guard yourself
defend defend defend right good then
wait he did you get boom boom right and
now I do if he wants that hit you've got
a garden space no he's not doing
anything just wait the do to get boom
got you see
yeah
you see so what is what technique he's
go killer go kill right there okay so
how did I do that right test him out
hurt him hurt him
boom okay then you go home and I wasn't
ready I'm gonna do it again right maybe
I could get it right over here I'm
thinking if he keeps pushing I'm gonna
get my knee in there but he wised up
right brought that elbow down because he
doesn't want to go here so he brought
his elbow back down right he brought it
back in you see something dude he kid
it'll look for it
boom and I got it yeah and I pass it to
the other arm do you think and I come
right back on top of it and I bring it
in and then roll it over you see without
huge portion of bullets okay take if you
have the arm shoulder can be attack
elbow can be attack risk and be attacked
fingers can be attacked when they can't
be attacked are to be passed and
isolated so this this elbow need to get
under yes now you can go to your knees
come around this head
right good to turn their weight just
rolling backwards there you go
[Music]
love oho given all this space give it
all that space okay so get the on
triangle good you gotta jump okay
truck let's finish it right so get to
the other side
[Music]
you